Hey, how are you? Haven't seen you in a
couple days. You all right?
Good.
[Silence]
Continuing in the book of prayer, the
chapters regarding the times of salah.
Mawaqit al salah. And we've discussed
all of the timings of prayer,
both
ideal times and at worst latest times of
each prayer.
We've also discussed what a person is to
do if they miss a prayer.
And now the author discusses the times
when it is impermissible to pray.
So,
a bit of a logical step here
I want to make.
When we make an exception to something,
when we make an exception to something,
which is more?
The exception
or that which the exception is from.
So, let me give you an example. If I say
for instance,
I'd you
to give me
$1
except 99 cents.
I want you to give me $1 save one pen
save 99 cents. What am I actually asking
for?
One penny.
Is that how we set things up? 100 people
came except for 99.
Right?
No.
The exception is always less.
Right? It's always less.
So, we did we say for instance,
you know, $1
save 20 cents, 10 cents, 5 cents. That's
how exceptions work. Illa. Fal
mustathna,
da'iman yakun aqal min al mustathna
minhu. The point of this is when we have
an exception, when we say it is
impermissible to pray during the
following times,
that means that the majority of the time
is permissible or impermissible?
Permissible.
That means that salah is permissible at
any hour of the day or night
except
three times. Except
one, two, three.
So, the majority is always what?
Permissibility. And the exception is the
impermissibility.
Now,
when we look at the times of prayer,
this narration of Uqbah ibn Amir, he
tells us that the prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam prohibited prayer
during three times, which means that he
generally advised that a person pray all
of the time, anytime, except for
three times. If a person were to make
the claim, "It is not permissible to
pray during this time." they would have
to have a clear-cut evidence for that.
Right? Because al asal al jawaz. And
this is exactly what the prophet said.
He said sallallahu alaihi wasallam in a
narration in a sunan,
What does that mean? Prayer is the best
thing to fill time with.
You have some extra time on your hands?
It's the best thing. That's the best
thing to to spend your time in if you're
unsure what to do with it.
Uqbah ibn Amir, radiyallahu anhu,
he says,
[Silence]
He says, "Three times of the day of
night or in night in which the messenger
of Allah, sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
would prohibit us from both praying or
burying our dead during these three
times."
Now, this means
that the majority of the time
it is permissible or impermissible to
pray?
Permissible. This means that during the
majority of the day and night, it is
permissible or impermissible to bury the
dead?
Say it. Permissible. Why are you
hesitating? The reason you're hesitating
is you've never been to a funeral at
night.
That's why. You're thinking, how bizarre
would it be
to have a funeral at night? And I agree.
That would be very strange.
However, it's not because it's
impermissible. It's because it's
extremely inconvenient. It's because
it's slightly creepy. It's because
people are sleeping and not out. And the
point of janazah is to have as many
people come to pray as possible.
The more people you can have making
salah over a person, over a deceased,
the better.
But this doesn't mean that it is
impermissible to bury during the night
time. Uthman ibn Affan was buried at
night. Ali ibn Abi Talib was buried at
night.
Asim ibn Thabit was buried at night.
Many companions were buried at night.
And during battle, they would always
bury whenever the casualties occurred,
right? If we're having a long battle, 10
days, 15, 20 days of battle, battle
would usually stop at nightfall. You
can't see anymore. So, both camps, both
sides of the battle would go back and,
you know, tend to their dead and so
forth. And they would bury during that
time. It's very common
during the time of the companions
radiyallahu anhu to bury at night.
There's nothing impermissible about it
other than it may not always be
appropriate.
So, there's a big difference between
appropriate and
between inappropriate and impermissible,
right? So, these three times
[Arabic recitation]
prohibited prayer
and prohibited the burial of the dead
during these three times. He says,
Hina
tub
[Arabic recitation]
eastern horizon, when it's rising, until
it rises high enough over the horizon in
the sky. And we said that's about how
many minutes between when the
the disc of the sun first peaks over the
eastern horizon until it is permissible
to pray again?
15 minutes.
Right? It's about 15 minutes. So, from
the moment of sunrise
until it is permissible to pray again is
15 minutes.
Number two.
He says,
He says the second time of day is when
the sun is at exactly high noon. It's at
exactly its zenith.
In the exact middle of the sky, if we
were on the equator,
which we're pretty close, and
it was exactly noon,
if we had a stick in the ground, there
would be no shadow.
Cuz the sun would be directly above it.
Down.
This is when it is impermissible to
pray.
And it becomes permissible again once
the sun crosses its zenith
from the eastern horizon to the west,
and the sun now is on the western side,
and the shadow is pointing back towards
where the sun came from,
and we have a little bit of shadow to
thanks
going towards the east, towards sunrise.
This is about how long?
15 minutes. It's about 15 minutes.
Number three. He says, "Wahina tadayafa
shamsu lil ghurubi hatta taghruba."
He says, "And the third is when the sun
is
is just about to set
over the horizon until it sets.
And that is the exact opposite of what
happened when at sunrise.
Right? It's the exact opposite.
So,
starting where?
Permissible after Fajr starts and then
the sun starts to set
in its final and its final
you know, in its final descent, if you
will,
or its
you know, in its final stage
until it sets under the horizon, which
is the Adhan of Maghrib. And this is how
many minutes before Maghrib Adhan?
15 minutes.
It's about 15 minutes.
So, to make that very easy, if we are to
say
when is it impermissible to pray or bury
the dead?
Number one,
15 minutes after sunrise.
Number two,
15 minutes before Zuhr.
Number three, 15 minutes before Maghrib.
That's to make it easy.
Right?
I'll repeat it again.
When is it impermissible
to pray
or bury the dead?
Number one, 15 minutes after sunrise.
Number two, 15 minutes before Zuhr.
Number three, 15 minutes
before Maghrib.
These times it is impermissible to pray
or bury the dead. Anything outside of
these times is permissible.
Is permissible. And when the issues of
burial, we have an entire book that we
will get to, which is the book of
funerals.
And we will inshallah, you know, if
we're alive and
we will
go through
all of funeral
you know, rights from the moment a
person
becomes ill for his final moments
all the way until the ground is settled
and even after the burial, what a person
does. All of this inshallah we will
discuss
in its due place. So, the takeaway
today is those three times it is
impermissible to
pray or bury the dead. Mas Allah
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
wastaghfirna
fi ta'atika
[Arabic recitation]